hey Mr Wonderful here how are you we're
in a very special place you know I love
watches we're in Caesar's Palace in Las
Vegas at one of the world's largest
watch
stores I'm in Las Vegas what do you
expect I'm going to do the Marilyn
Monroe walk down the stair shot this
store is so incredible you get the idea
of the depth the height of the ceilings
all the brands in here it's it's just a
watch Wonderland it really really is
there are so many different ideas to see
here I almost consider this a watch
Museum experience you see that logo over
there Carl F Boer let's go over there
this is a really remarkable brand in
horology come on Carl F
Booker lucern Switzerland
1988 the Grand Daddy this is one of the
oldest most esteemed brands in the world
you
know the only reason I could talk about
this brand with such knowledge is I'm a
vampire and I was there when it was
[Music]
founded that's right right in The
Vineyards of Switzerland yep I'm a
burundian vampire that's cuz I like Pino
grapes but never mind about that Gerard
perago and by the way because we're in
Las Vegas last night 3:00 in the morning
they dropped this brand new there's only
33 of these turbon look at the dial on
that thing that's what's so great about
being in the world's one of the world's
largest watch stores you never know what
you're going to find brand new ceramic
absolutely spectacular chopar I need
sunglasses near here look at the bling
on these watches isn't this incredible
look at the dial stop the madness Leo
German incredible dials Lin why you want
this brand fantastic price point for the
quality you get entrylevel watch why not
tag cure sporty sexy fantastic piece at
a great price I mean look at these
watches they make amazing
dials Omega why this is special to me my
very first watch the Speedmaster Moon
watch now this giant
stone is not paper mâché otherwise I'd
lift it up it's the real
deal kind of signifies the moon watch
thing part of the Omega aura this
Brand's
amazing tutor everybody knows Rolex owns
them they have some of the most amazing
case materials like ceramic like silver
and beautiful dials long legacy to this
piece and very affordable for the
quality you
get Grand SEO so many people don't know
that in the late 1800s the Japanese
started making watches from the
locksmith industry they had there what's
unique about Grand SEO why it's worth a
look see why you should come in and look
at everything the most incredible dial
Manufacturing in the world the Japanese
take pride in the craftsmanship of these
incredible textures on their dial Grand
SEO is crazy dials and the quality is
insane it's called the Grand Seiko
crunch when you dial it I have many
Grand
seikos love this
brand brightling you want a sexy Sports
look that also works on a tuxedo jeans
and t-shirts brightling it's got that
whole racing Vibe Aeronautics a lot
associated with this brand people love
it and a unique dial look Moser burst on
the scene with what incredible dials
insane dials amazing dials the look that
Moser has has taken it right to the top
relatively young but smoking hot Moser
blow PA yes that says
1735 I was there I'm a vampire fantastic
brand been around forever huge Legacy
unique dials spectacular value come here
and see it this is Masterworks multiple
Brands let's have a look first of all
Jacob Jacob and Co is crazy chicken
dials if you've got every other brand
and you don't have a Jacob that's what's
next look at
that yeah you know these actually come
from the planet Jacob they're not even
made on Earth Frank Mueller very very
distinctive looking watch very very
famous brand First Watch I ever bought
my
wife foret 1775 one of the famous First
Watch makers what a brand legendary
incredible dials of course collectors
appreciate it it's been legendary in
Europe Forever Mr Wonderful here no one
needs a watch but everybody wants one
why because it marks a moment of time in
your life many Watchers appreciate and
value over time that's why I created
Wonder care want to learn more about
insuring your watch go to wonder
care.com one of the great features of
these Booker stores whether you're in
Las Vegas or New York or many others is
the pre-owned section now one of the
great challenges in watch collecting is
if you can't buy the piece as a primary
retail product and there's many watches
you can't do that because the demand is
insatiable for so many Brands you can go
to the secondary market now the
challenge with the open secondary market
and let me just tell it to you straight
it's fraud that's right watches like the
steel white face Daytona no one can know
for sure but as much as 10% of those are
fake they're such in demand that fak
sers if you want to call them that fake
watch makers work very hard to make fake
watches and sell them to you in the
aftermarket as it's called how do you
avoid that well you come here the
pre-owned section of Booker's store
where every single watch is
authenticated you get a 2-year warranty
watch makers look at it to make sure
it's real you get new papers for it and
you know with certainty that the watch
is real and that's what really really
matters because these watches sell in
most cases at a premium you know if
you're buying a used Rolex you're going
to pay more but at least you're going to
get it and it's going to be real and
you're going to get a warranty so a lot
of the pieces that are so coveted you
will find here
because let's face it Booker has tens of
thousands of clients many of them trade
watches in they bring them back to where
they bought them they get authenticated
they get repackaged they get new papers
issued and you get a warranty so that's
fantastic here we are there's many
amazing pieces in here I'm not going to
walk you through every one of them andd
be here for hours but I just wanted to
let you know this exists because people
ask me all the time can you look at this
Rolex for me I said it's not me you've
got to get it authenticated you've got
to go to an authorized dealer of Rolex
that know the the heritage of the watch
the caliber of the watch the serial
number of the watch and only they can
authenticate it for you I arrest my case
your honor you can't find this many time
pieces on display anywhere so if you're
in Las Vegas you've got to check this
out this is one of the marvels of this
city absolutely
beautiful